a rest and incarceration are very blunt
tools and we have lots of evidence that
these tools are overused in our current
society and so before you make something
a crime you need to have a really high
bar for how certain you are that this is
worth ruining a person's life and
ruining their family's life boom what's
up everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don Saucon we are still in
Cambridge in Massachusetts we are now
going to be talking about criminal
justice reform we have Elizabeth Edwards
joining us on the show hello hi thanks
so much for coming on the show where
they appreciate it and it's a pleasure
to be here we're really excited we're
gonna have a lot of great conversation
Elizabeth's background as epics he spent
four years as a representative in New
Hampshire's legislature from 2014 to
2018 her main focus was criminal justice
reform and she was the first
representative sponsor a bill that would
decriminalize sex work so we're gonna be
talking about a lot of that journey and
harm reduction prison civil liberties
very excited to get into this all right
Elizabeth let's start things off with
your journey you know who are you how
did you become who you are today yeah I
think that a my interest in politics
stemmed from conversations with my
father from a very young age we listened
to a lot of talk radio we watched a lot
of news and he was always very
interested in my opinion I think
starting in second grade I would get
into arguments with my teacher about
when it seemed like they had some kind
of political slant so I've always been
but I still managed to pull off being
the teacher's pet somehow so that was
that was who I was from a young age I
wanted to be a Supreme Court justice in
middle school that was
career aspiration back then so I've
always cared a lot about politics and
then in college I became an anarchist
yeah this is a wild turn in the story a
quick point is that it's cool that you
and your father had so many so much
discourse around news and politics
growing up because that's a good way to
get engaged with what's happening in the
world get the kids engaged and
especially when the adults are hearing
out the young people's opinions and
ideas yeah sure although there's always
the nature versus nurture question right
like my sister
barely cares at all about politics so is
it my dad's is it my dad's genes is that
why we care about this stuff or is it
the conversations we had I don't know
yeah that's the issue your sister
doesn't care it's not really no she like
I don't think she even voted you were
like really engaged she was not engaging
in the political conversations with him
as much I don't know it's hard to say
there's like like I remember my
conversations with him and I think and
he tried to get her interested certainly
because it's what he's passionate about
but she wasn't saying she wanted abuse
or justice okay so then anarchist
in in college was interesting okay and
this is in New York yeah I went to a
State University of New York the college
at brockport which is where I met my
wife and I think that when I started
college okay so when I started college I
was in ROTC and I wanted it's pretty
it's a pretty interesting evolution so I
was in ROTC and I had political beliefs
that were pretty close to my dad's
political beliefs which was kind of like
a pre Trump obviously kind of like a
small government conservative almost and
like socially liberal fiscally
conservative but also very
kind of hawkish on foreign policy and so
I wanted to join the military to fight
the terrorists and that's how I was when
I joined well that's what I thought was
like at the time I was like a proto
proto ei that's the conference we're at
right now is ehe ex and effective
altruism right yeah so it's always like
well what is the what is the best way
that I can make the world a better place
is basically the central question of EI
and I had never heard of EI at this time
of course but a lot of people answer
that question with I want to join the
military and so that was my plan and
then it's a good thing that I left ROTC
after a year largely because of Don't
Ask Don't Tell in my relationship with
my girlfriend at the time
Tiki teaches about that policy right
Don't Ask Don't Tell said that you're
allowed to have gay feelings as long as
nobody finds out about it so that was
really rough being a college student my
first real relationship my first real
romantic relationship was with another
girl and the campus was my home where I
you know like go to the dining hall and
I couldn't show physical affection to
her because other cadets could be in the
dining hall and so I only only lasted an
ROTC for a year before I left and it was
very convenient that I did leave because
it would have been really awkward to be
a senior and an anarchist and in ROTC
[Laughter]
yeah so this is this is is this policy
still in know Don't Ask Don't Tell was
repealed was it implemented by and why
Bill Clinton well it was seen as the
forum because the the previous policy
was you have to like for two
to join the military you have to
forswear any kind of homosexual feelings
or conduct so this was like it's okay to
be a homosexual as long as you don't
talk about it so it was actually it was
a step in the right direction in the
early nineties Wow
Wow see you couldn't you actually when
you joined pre Clinton you free Clinton
they would ask you are you a homosexual
whoa yeah yeah and that would disqualify
you damn this is some old code yeah yeah
it's good to see us moving in new code
yeah into new code yep yeah yeah and so
is there now a new policy in place that
is like you can be whoever you yeah it's
the I mean there are still like rules of
conduct around like sex and romance in
the military like for example like
adultery is strongly punished in the
military but you can but the same rules
apply to gay relationships as straight
relationships okay so you there's now
you can openly be good yeah you can be
open the game oh that's yeah huge step
in oh yeah that's Wow yeah yeah cool
okay great thank you for teaching us
about this yeah all right so then so
then you know what was the whole
anarchist okay so so basically I had
like the makings of a little of like a
libertarian except that I thought like a
strong national defense was essential
for protect for spreading democracy
abroad and protecting America and
killing bad people and and then I read a
book by Ron Paul and it basically
explained the concept of blowback in a
way I found really convincing that
American foreign policy creates conflict
and creates terrorists and does more
harm than good which again goes back to
me being sort of like a proto
ei is that like well does this satisfy
the cost-benefit analysis and I think
and I and I was convinced by Ron Paul's
book that the answer was no and so it
was like well if you don't even need a
government for to you know to have a
strong military then at that point I was
like well what do you even need a
government for I read another book
called healing our world and an age of
aggression which is a very peace and
love title it's by a woman named dr.
Mary Ruhr and that book laid out
basically why you should the moral and
consequentialist case for never using
government for anything for any aim
whatsoever always using private industry
for like maybe yeah private action
private action private charity all that
stuff for everything and I found that
book very convincing I didn't a probably
because it accorded with my beliefs it
with the way that my beliefs were
already leaning at the time right and
that was the last basically the last
straw another thing that was going on
around that time was that it was the
2008 presidential election and I really
wanted to vote in it because it was the
first year I could vote and I was a
junior in college at this point and the
I didn't want to vote for John McCain or
Barack Obama and I watched the
especially because after watching the
vice presidential debate at about five
minutes and it made me cry I started
crying watching Sarah Palin and Joe
Biden give the same answer to a question
like the same completely meaningless
answer full of like populist drivel to a
question about preventing future
financial crises and I started crying
with despair for the future of the
country and
my my girlfriend turned the TV off her
door yes so I didn't have any hope I was
like there's no hope for America and I
still wanted to vote so I started
researching third parties and I was I
went down the Wikipedia rabbit hole and
that's how I found out about the Free
State Project okay cool
all right so quick pre Free State
Project I think what you brought up is
so interesting about how some of the
actions that have been taken throughout
time even all let's say six million
years of this human evolution that
whenever we think that we're you know
going in and making an intervention in
someone else's a life and their and
their land and their peace and dignity
that sometimes these these recoils
happen that are worse that make things
worse than just having somehow being
able to have a discourse about it and
just be at peace yeah yeah making
decisions for other people is a very
fraught and dangerous activity at this
point in my life I think that sometimes
we should do it anyway but with a lot of
caution interesting and could you maybe
give us an idea of what that would look
like sure like I think publicly-funded
vaccination programs are a good example
of this coordination any kind of
coordination problem where any one
person would be worse off doing the
thing but everybody would be better off
if everybody did the thing that's a
coordination problem and it's a good
candidate for a type of thing that the
government ought to do Oh interesting
okay so the coordination problems where
everyone's better off if they if we all
do it like no one ever kills anyone like
things like that
well more I think a really good example
is
like air and water pollution oh yeah is
because like I would be better off if I
like created a product and sent and
created externalities that I didn't
really have to worry about like you know
when I pollute the air with my economic
output I only face you know 1 7
billionth of the cost of that whereas I
get all of the profits for myself so
this is clearly a coordination problem
because everybody has the incentive to
profit at the expense of air and water
simply because the air and water are
it's very difficult to internalize those
externalities right so I think Erin
water pollution is something that the
private sector can't really solve now on
the other hand you always have to ask
yourself is the government also
polluting our air and water like it's
not just private actors so how do we
treat the air and the water and our
biosphere as a public good that we
harmonize with yeah yeah completely
interesting ok so then it was the the
free the free state project project and
you heard about that in New York and
then you moved to New Hampshire yeah so
I found out about the Free State Project
and I thought oh good I don't have to
worry about the country as a whole like
obviously the country as a whole is is
too hard it's too much so I'm just going
to these people have this idea to just
focus on one state and they voted and
they picked New Hampshire so all of the
Liberty activists which is what Free
Staters often refer to themselves as are
going to move to New Hampshire and we're
going to at least create an island of as
little government as possible or
preserve earth in a lot of cases just
preserve the small government at those
that New Hampshire already has because
it is a very like
lene let's say lien state when it comes
to the state government so how you teach
us about how its lien yeah sure so for
example in New Hampshire there's no
general sales tax on goods and there is
also no state income tax there's like a
capital gains tax but no tax on regular
income no tax on regular income yeah
none right exactly
I mean it you have to pay your federal
not have to pay federal but there's no
state income tax and no
medicare/medicaid yes those are all
federal services so you get all those
get those but not state tax so you're
paying only what percent then total
whatever your federal whatever your
federal tax whatever so so in it that
means that the state government largely
resorts to property taxes local and
state governments are Labour's or chains
and there is a small capital gains tax
yeah and there's also like a rooms and
meals tax so if you go to a restaurant
yeah you're paying a sales you're paying
a tax on the food at the restaurant and
if you buy cigarettes you're paying a
state tax on the cigarettes but there's
no like there's no like interesting
blanket sales tax no blanket feel sorry
if I eat at a restaurant I pay a tax and
if I get cigarettes I would say that
property taxes in Vegas do you think oh
yeah how many taxes are like and that's
the thing that a lot of people complain
about is they say well maybe if we had
an income tax our property taxes
wouldn't be so high but I think that in
state I think that like historically
states that implement an income tax with
the idea that oh this will allow us to
reduce property taxes that doesn't
actually happen
the overall tax burden just goes up so
and then it does a is relying on mostly
property tax also potentially make it so
that the sliding scale of who pays the
most taxes is a little more fair those
that have like really good yeah I mean I
think if you're looking at it from the
perspective of what kind of taxes are
the most justifiable like morally which
is not a particularly it's not really a
consequentialist question well you could
be a consequentialist about it and say
like a land value taxes the causes the
least amount of distortion like economic
distortion and deadweight loss so that's
one reason to like land value taxes
which isn't quite which isn't the same
as property taxes but it's in the sort
of the same category right and then but
also from a more of a deontological
standpoint which is where a lot of
libertarians are coming from I think
that property tax is more justifiable
because you're saying you can't come on
to this land in the state is the one
enforcing that people aren't allowed to
trespass on this land that you've
claimed although in theory like how did
you get the right to that land you know
it was you go back far enough that was
taken from somebody else it was taken it
was taken out of the public Commons and
assigned to one person and so you are
restricting somebody's freedom of
movement by claiming land as your own so
interesting some you know I'm very
familiar with all the infighting amongst
libertarians and anarchists and like
pseudo anarchists and MIT artists and
all the little subgroups because I was
embroiled in that culture in New
Hampshire for several years and that led
you to decide to want to run well I I
wanted to run for office because I
wanted to at the time I wanted to reduce
the suffering caused by government I was
focused on that suffering caused by
government because
guest this is the criminal-justice room
and that's what yes and that's why I was
focused on criminal justice reform is
because our criminal justice system
causes so much pain and suffering and of
course I still do believe that and I
think a lot of I think a lot if not a
majority of prison sentences are
unjustifiable especially focused on
rehabilitating as much as we are just
incarcerated yeah yeah and you know it's
everybody agrees that the incarceration
rate in this country is out of control
out of control
I heard there's more people in jail here
than in China and China has like four
times the population of the United
States
you mean total or per capita yeah total
total but wouldn't it wouldn't surprise
me it would not surprise me which is a
crazy stat if that's if that's you know
if that's true that's with four times
the population how do we have more
people in jail that yeah it's pretty
messed up yeah
okay so then um you know your passion
for criminal justice reform
you know you ticked on prisons there I
want to know you know I also kind of you
know baking this into how you got
involved in in in New Hampshire's
legislature but but really just on
solving prisons rehabilitating yeah
whether your thoughts there oh man I
think in general when it comes to policy
change my experience anyway is that it's
easier to advocate at the margin for
policies that reduce and slink and keep
people out of prison in the first place
than it is to fix conditions in prisons
because there's
it when it well first of all you can
only you could only be an expert in one
of these things this is one of the
things that I didn't really realize is
that you can either be is that learning
about prison reform and become and
becoming the kind of person who can
advocate for changes in the design and
functioning and purpose of Prisons
is its own project and is separate from
the question of should this be a crime
and should people go to jail for it
and so even though I see it as like both
of those things as are part of the
broader issue of criminal justice reform
is it was really hard to try to keep
both of to keep both of those balls in
the air that's what I found personally
and also another issue is that when it
comes to getting people to testify in
favor of a bill it's really hard to get
prisoners to testify because they're in
prison and usually for any misguided law
you can find somebody who would say if I
had ever been caught for this I would be
in jail but I'm not in jail right now
like by the grace of God you can find
that kind of person but somebody who has
who has been caught and has been to jail
is automatically less credible to
legislators because legislators have
legislators tend to have a lot of faith
in systems and in institutions way too
much faith in institutions because
there's a selection effect where the
kind of people who run for office are
the kind of people who had relatively
easy life so the institution served them
well Wow yeah Wow what did you call that
effect the it's a selection a selection
effect yeah because in order to run for
office it's more likely that you will be
running for office if you have had a you
know middle-class y-yeah a good life a
good life where you didn't have to
struggle for food yeah or for love or
compassion
or you know or all these other basic
needs physiological needs that yeah it's
it's much yeah and a lot of the time we
need that that's why potentially if we
find people that are in the
Legislature's of the state and even in
the Congress level that it would be a
profound shift in awareness for a
country if they had a more diverse
socioeconomic us if they yeah because
then you gain the empathy from what it's
like to to be behind the eyes of someone
that didn't come from that same
homogenized yeah and I think this effect
is even worse in New Hampshire because
legislators are not really paid they're
paid $100 a year $100 so it's mainly be
live well it's mainly retirees I was
supported by my wife and I did like some
side jobs and stuff like that but it's
mainly retirees the median age of the
New Hampshire State House is 67 Wow so
these are people who had the financial
well-being to retire first of all
because some people never get to retire
um and people who you know have the good
health in their retirement to take on
what is essentially a volunteer position
so that goes back to people who had
relatively easy lives although I'm not
saying everybody I mean really when you
get right down to it nobody has an easy
life but there's harder lives and easier
lives right
I really appreciated how when you're
describing about the prison system that
it's important to you're juggling these
balls and that and you're talking about
the extreme difficulty of the nuance and
all the variables that are coming in but
really it a out of at a perspective of
of water
what is it something ridiculous like
almost 50% of people incarcerated in
jail student cannabis still or something
no it's not it's not something it's if
you look at like drug-related offenses
it's around 50% total drug-related
offenses around 50% I think so yeah if
you include like jails and prisons
cannabis is still like a good chunk of
that it's a yeah it's a good chunk but
it's nowhere close to 50% of the total
incarcerated probably need to learn
about that more I went I went I was
incarcerated for four months for having
cannabis in South Dakota oh my gosh
yeah so this these types of yeah because
I always think about the lost potential
yeah oh yeah and that's something that
we don't track is a cost usually we talk
about like one of the there's the scene
costs and the unseen costs and one of
the scene costs is like well how much
does it costs to build a prison you know
pay the prison guards and stuff like
that but the costs that are almost never
factored in is like the lost economic
output of a person who is now who cannot
like contribute to the economy and
generate value and generate wealth for
himself and his community because he has
this on his record and it doesn't even
take a conviction to do that an arrest
can do that
yeah the reform is so important and I'm
really excited to continue hearing about
you know you and hopefully other people
around the country that are working on
this and around the world
okay so that was that was prisons when
we have other you know besides you know
civil liberties harm reduction and then
the sec worker sex worker cameras right
well and the whole other thing was that
I when I won my primary in 2014 I was an
anarchist but then by the time I was
sworn in I wasn't really anything
anymore
because I had this crisis of faith
and that's what led me to this community
in this conference was I was questioning
all of my beliefs because I wanted to do
a good job at decision-making in policy
so that was pretty wild
getting sworn in and not really knowing
feeling like the ground was moving under
my feet and like my dogma was
insufficient and misguided was very
uncertain time in my life from yeah so
you went from getting sworn in as an
anarchist feeling this you know ground
shift from under you and then you're
surrounded by 67 year olds on average
yeah I mean by and large I think a lot
of people assume that it was really hard
for me because I'm like a young woman
there was the occasional patronizing
comment but the thing that made it hard
was that I had been this fringe activist
I had been arrested for civil
disobedience I had associated with the
Free State Project and that was because
I had this Dogma in this ideology that I
didn't really question and when I came
when I learned about effective altruism
and just like I started examining my
cognitive biases a lot more closely in
general I became I shifted my focus and
I still in criminal justice reform
thankfully was something that my old
self cared about and my new self cared
about like I checked all of my all of my
reasons for caring about criminal
justice reform and they all still
applied like yes there is a vast amount
of very expensive and very unnecessary
suffering in this system like that that
has that still held so at least I was
still able to work on the primary issue
that I had wanted to work on before I
ran for office
okay so that was a relief and so some of
the ways that I did that was I helped
people with their good ideas like some
of the good ideas we're making narcan
available too I like more available to
third parties narcan immediately
reverses the effects of an opiate
overdose so so it's good to have that in
as many people's hands as possible
pretty much so that fewer people died of
overdoses which are themselves largely
an artifact of the war on drugs and the
inability to know what's in your what's
in your purchase right and then nine
eleven eighty laws was another thing I
helped out with which is saying that if
you call 9-1-1 you will not be arrested
for drug possession and the person over
having a medical emergency will not be
arrested for drug possession so because
people were scared to call 9-1-1 because
they didn't want to go to jail yeah and
so they would take out their friend's ID
and you know put it somewhere easily
visible prop his body up call 911 and
leave which is not well because that
would mean that was the incentives was
to get out of there before the cops and
the EMTs get there so 911 I mean any
laws make it less likely that people do
that and more likely that people do call
the ambulance
that's an that's that's a really
important yeah so I was a co-sponsor on
both of those bills another bill that we
got passed was we legalized needle
exchanges it was which our needle
exchanges are robustly supported in the
harm reduction in public health
literature for reducing the spread of
HIV and hepatitis and also like
interacting with a syringe service
program makes people more likely to get
help for their addiction issues so even
apart from the direct effects of there's
less at HIV there's fewer there are
fewer Hep C transmissions there's the
indirect effect of well and now people
feel
couldn't connected and cared about by
health care professionals and so they
get assistance they get on you know a
replacement therapy like methadone
replacement or and they they seek the
the treatment model that would work best
for them and where they are in their
stage of life and in their stage of
addiction so anyway just really like
really basic stuff like that like we
can't we're not ending the war on drugs
today but we're going to make it more
likely that people come out of it alive
and being suffering was your big tag
yeah
and and apart from drug prohibition
which obviously there are a lot of
politicians who oppose that not enough
but a lot of politicians who oppose that
I read this report from Amnesty
International that said that all
governments worldwide should
decriminalize all aspects of adult
consensual adult sex work and this was
in agreement with the World Health
Organization and with the UN Commission
on HIV and AIDS that said that these
these studies these broad this broad
consensus among public health experts
and human rights advocates that sex work
should be decriminalized but there
wasn't a single American politician who
was willing to put their face to that
policy it was whoa and I thought well I
don't mind putting I don't mind sticking
my name on that and working on this and
so that's kind of the thing that I
became the best known for was my
advocacy for sex workers rights the bill
of course didn't pass it's more of a 10
or 20 year project than a three or four
year project but my goal was to start
the conversation and we now have a few
presidential candidates who are open
about supporting sex work
decriminalization so
I think I contributed to that momentum
which is a good feeling yeah yeah and
then what would you say is the most
important sort of takeaway especially
from the sex work decriminalization
oh gosh
for policymakers I would say that arrest
and incarceration are very blunt tools
and we have lots of evidence that these
tools are overused in our current
society and so before you make something
a crime you need to have a really high
bar for how certain you are that this is
worth ruining a person's life and
ruining their family's life and sex work
criminalization does not meet that
standard at all I think it's partially
about what people choose to do there
with their bodies it's a bodily
sovereignty issue it's about control of
female sexuality and I mean because most
sex workers are female and the
demonization of women who charge instead
of fitting into more traditional models
of relationships and sexuality
it's about criminalization of
impoverished women because lots of women
it's because sex work is something you
can do with no education right so it's
something that a lot of and it's
something that you can do without a lot
of like there's a low barrier to entry
so it's a way of controlling and
punishing women in poverty and a lot of
people point to the Nordic model and say
well what if we just made it illegal for
the people who are paying for it and the
answer is that the evidence doesn't
really support that model because it
makes it harder for sex workers to
screen their clients it makes it so that
the police still see sex workers as
contributing to a criminal enterprise
even if they can't arrest the sex worker
they still see them as
you know collaborators in crime so what
you want is a sec is a sex worker who
can go to police when she's raped or
robbed you can go a sex worker can go to
the police when she suspects that
somebody in somebody is being trafficked
a sex worker who can is happy and
hopeful about going to the police when
her friend doesn't show up the next day
the homicide rate of us sex workers is
200 per hundred thousand which is whoa
in just it's basically unthinkable so
there's a lot of work to do yeah I don't
think I've ever you know you really
unpacked it in the nuance really well
there it's obvious that you've been
spending a lot of time thinking about it
yeah and then you also I don't think
anyone's ever you know made it so clear
that before someone makes something a
crime an officer makes something a crime
to really think out the effect that it
has on the person and the person's
family that's a really interesting way
of saying it and if we can do criminal
justice reform to the point where I'm
interested to hear your take on this but
a lot of the a lot of the issues that
civilization has in its code we
sometimes argue that if we were just to
have slowed down and think better about
how we want to you know build the future
you know in a way that we're all
physiological needs are met everyone's
able to creatively flourish we're more
spiritually enlightened we're not
violent against each other these types
of things what do you think about that
oh gosh it sounds great I'm a little
skeptical of utopian visions because
well for a lot of reasons
I mean first off they were just so far
away from anything like that there's
just still so much broken in this world
so the gap between here and there but
also that a lot of utopian visions are
[Music]
when people try to enact them there's
often violence and sort of dystopian
outcomes I would love if people were
more careful about institutional design
and I think that reforming the
decision-making processes at
institutions even just to do like sort
of basic basic best practices when it
comes to like a group decision like we
know what makes groups make bad
decisions like a conformity pressure for
instance and there are ways to reduce
conformity pressure but a lot of times
this sort of like basic how do we get
this group to make a good choice a lot
of those those things that we already
know about social psychology are just
not followed in public and private
organizations I know they certainly were
often not followed in committees in the
New Hampshire legislature and are not
followed in legislatures and committees
and groups of policymakers all over the
country and all over the world so
instead of imagining and instead of
thinking oh well we can make sure
everybody's needs are met and everybody
is happy I try to focus on a little
smaller thing like let's make people
less reckless like just a like a little
less reckless for right now there's so
much that's a way to slowly yeah that's
a tight rate peace is by decreasing
recklessly yeah yeah that's that's a
good way to put it yeah I like that a
lot it was a bit two quick questions on
something out we like to ask these
questions to our guests on this so first
question is if you think we're in a
simulation
oh gosh I'm gonna say no but I
understand the argument and I find the
argument a bit unnerving yeah we like to
like to ask question it's a fun one and
the other question is what do you think
is the most beautiful thing in the world
my wife tell us why she has these
freckles all over her face and they even
like extend onto her upper lip if you
look really closely which is so cute and
the way that she wakes up in the morning
like when the morning light is on her
face and she has it's like a it's like a
sunrise like the pink like the pink on
her cheeks and like the really light
purple bluish undertones under her eyes
and like the like peachy complexion and
her eyes are blue like the sky and so
it's just like the sunrise on a human
face and it's the face of the person
that I married and that I want to spend
this entire lifetime with so I know
that's a really cheesy answer but I love
the way that you described such detail
on the and the indoor most beautiful
thing yeah yeah thank you so much for
coming on our show and talking to us a
teaching us this has been so it like
you're very welcome such a pleasure
thank you thank you thank you
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we would love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode go and talk to more people about
criminal justice reform and what exactly
goes into deploying these types of
changes into our world share with your
friends your family communities online
coworkers also go and support the
artists and entrepreneurs that you
believe in support organizations around
the world that you believe in
simulations links are below help us
continue doing cool things like coming
to Cambridge to conduct interviews and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in
and we will see you soon peace